[Music]
we're now moving to a part of the year
which I always look forward to and
that's the opportunity to really
celebrate those individuals that are
championing the fiber cause and really
moving the needle with regard to making
fiber capacity and fiber availability
available to all European citizens and
as always each year we have our awards
for both the individuals within the
fiber to the home industry those
individuals that have shown that
capability to really drive change
through the operators that they work for
or the organizations that they engage
with within the industry to drive change
and we also have the operator award as
well and this is where we really try to
identify specific operator that has gone
above and beyond and what all the other
operators would in the market have done
in order to bring fiber capability and
to the citizens in the markets that they
operate within um this year was quite
unusual from the point of view I think
on the back of all of the activity that
we've got with fiber-to-the-home
build-outs across Europe happening in
parallel the amount of choice that we
had as the board of directors would
indicate the winners of our two awards
and I think it's fair to say it was
unprecedented I think it's the first
time that we've actually been had way
too much choice now don't get me wrong
this is a fantastic this is a
first-class problem for us to have
because it means things are really
moving out there it means the operators
are really investing and it also means
that the consumers are really buying
those services so this is a problem that
we want to have am going forward as with
tradition with this session I normally
try and use this session as well just to
give you a little sneak preview with
regard to what else is happening in the
fibre industry we will be sharing
details during the keynote sessions
later this afternoon with regard to the
updated fiber-to-the-home count
panorama which I know many of you in the
room use as part of your data sets to
drive your business models to convince
investors to invest and even just to get
a better feel for the competitive
landscape out there but before we delve
into and identifying our Award winners
this year I'd like to try and give you a
little bit of insight with regard to the
very latest fiber-to-the-home council
panorama which is the very most up to
date and information I can see all the
phones
camera phones coming out straight away
and the session this afternoon and I
think it's session 8 if I remember
correctly will be going through all of
the detail of this you'll have plenty of
opportunity to grab some snap static but
I think some of the key things that are
worth noting at this point is as I
mentioned earlier during the opening
keynote we've now got 36.4% of european
homes that can avail of a full fiber
connection which is a fantastic
achievement and that's on the back of a
lot of momentum which is only continuing
to gain pace as we go forward and with
40 set 40% as subscriptions and across
those fibre footprints where they're
available again as I mentioned earlier
the consumer awareness is increasing out
there all the time which we think is
particularly important we've seen the UK
market enter into the permit panorama
with a level of force they're already up
to 1.3 percent of household
subscriptions today and those
subscriptions are up by 83 percent which
is a big achievement it's worth noting
that Spain Spain has surpassed Sweden so
Sweden for a long long time has held up
position up towards the very top of the
panorama Spain because of all the effort
they've been putting in over the last
couple of years have really massively
grown their market share with regard to
homes connected and subscribers on those
networks and Spain has done really well
now to display Sweden on that front so
no pressure no sweetener you just need
to re-engage and up the game again and
if we look at the how we go forward
within the market I think these types of
studies these panoramas are one of the
best tools that we've got available to
us within the industry
these are the tools that allow us to put
pressure at a governmental level because
it really is kind of a a name and shame
of where people are at versus their
peers within Europe and for a lot of
governments I do know this can be a
significant source of embarrassment so I
would encourage you to go along to the
session this afternoon to get greater
insight as to which markets are really
starting to react and make those
investments to either get themselves off
the bottom of the list or try and push
themselves further up the list
so with that sneak preview behind us I'd
like to focus on the order of business
which is really identifying our
champions in the fibre industry stee
individuals and the operators those who
are outstanding amongst their peers
within the industry to kick things off
with this year's 2019 fiber-to-the-home
council individual award this year's
recipient is not someone who's new to
either to telecoms industry or the fibre
industry this individual is a serial
entrepreneur an individual whose
personal aim is to bring gigabit fiber
connectivity throughout the market that
they operate in they drive their current
business despite at being a
well-established business with many
years of very very high levels of growth
and a very large satisfied customer base
they really try to drive their business
with a start-up mentality a can-do type
mentality and from a culture perspective
they implement a principle called rise
which really focuses on everybody within
the organization taking responsibility
using intelligence approaching their
task at hand with zeal and anticipating
or accepting nothing else but absolute
excellence when dealing with their
customer and dealing with the
infrastructure that they're building
ladies and gentlemen I'm delighted to be
able to announce that the 2019 winner of
the individual fiber-to-the-home Council
award is Dana Toback the CEO of hyper
optic
now unfortunately Dana's not able to
join us today
I actually saw Dana at Mobile World
Congress there week and a half ago
thereabouts and I can oh I can only say
she was exhausted I think the level of
activity that's been going on within her
business I know they've been fundraising
etc has really taken its toll and Dana
is actually she's out of the office at
the moment due to illness and I think a
lot of that stems from the amount of
activity that she's had to deal with and
thankfully Pascal Costard their CTO has
joined us today and Pascal is going to
accept the award on behalf of Dana
please give a warm welcome to Pascal
Pascal
congratulations to Dana as well thank
you thank you very much our next award
is the operator award and this year's
winner of the operator award many of us
know this operator for their activities
and as an incumbent however despite
their incumbents paid the incumbent
parents massive activities in
fiber-to-the-home
this is not the reason that they were
selected as a challenger this operator
is proven that independent of their
parent they've been able to really shake
up the fiber market in which they
operate with an objective of reaching 16
million households by 2020 with its own
fiber to the home network and
incidentally this operator is one of the
most profitable of the subsidiaries
within its parent which says a lot about
the business model for fibre to the home
that they're building ash they are
positioning themselves for 5g also and
their fiber assets will have a huge role
to play as per as part of that so ladies
and gentlemen I'm delighted to announce
that the winner of the fiber at home
council operator award
is if I can get our clicker to click is
are in Spain please give a warm
congratulations to our in Spain curve a
pass a layer of orange group the deputy
CEO and chairman is going to join me on
stage and accept the award on behalf of
orange group congratulations well done
thank you very much fantastic thank you
well done again Cheers just to says that
as that's been expressed we are quite
proud to to win this award as a
challenger even if it's part of a bigger
group bazoo as a challenge with this
group to get the cap extra Spain as well
we'll be in tough France trying to
capture most of the capex forints group
we are we have been fighting year after
year to be able to build this
infrastructure but also to share it with
others as I try to explain so it's a mix
of our own infrastructure plus
cooperation plus wholesale and I see
it's a success we need to have for
building the infrastructure of tomorrow
in this continent thank you
so ladies and gentlemen this concludes
our individual and operator awards for
this year please do remember we also
have the inaugural charles cow award
tomorrow a 3 p.m. so please do try and
come along to see who's going to be the
first winner of that very very special
award we break now for lunch and
activities resume per the normal
schedule at 2:30 p.m. thank you very
much
you